what's up so this video is going to be
the video where i show you guys the
results of our election poll that i
posted in my last video and i'm hoping
that this video is not the first time
that you're informed of who actually won
the presidential election and if it is
please tell me why you don't know now
before we get down to business i noticed
in the comments other than all of your
barack obama and mitt romney debates
complaints cheering fighting whatever
you want to call it there were a lot of
questions as to what happened to my hair
because one side seemed to be a little
too long and the other side seemed to be
a little too short so what happened was
i was playing call of duty and i had my
headset on and my hair got tangled and i
lost a match and i ripped the headset
off of my head and my hair was still
stuck in it i had to do a little trim
but for you guys i wouldn't got a
haircut
and now for the moments you've all been
waiting for the results of our mock
election pool who will cool
thank you to all 14 097 of you who
participated 43 of you were male and 57
of you were female put your hands up
hands up can i get maybe some
suspenseful music or perhaps a drum roll
i'll take either or so play it now
so congratulations to barack obama who
not only won the real election but he
also won our mock election too i'm sure
he's most excited about that 76.3
percent of you guys voted for barack and
mitch sorry but only 23.7 of our viewers
voted for you i said i was sorry i had
to not log onto facebook i'm still kind
of avoiding it because people are so
crazy and politically angry or
politically excited it's hard to read
these things there were so many people
on facebook who were saying they are
embarrassed to be living in their
current state because of the outcome i
mean that's a pretty strong freaking
statement so i decided to go to a few of
these people's profiles to see if they
actually ended up voting no they did it
so if you did not vote do not get to say
that you are mad about living your state
because of the outcome because you
didn't even go to vote yourself so
you suck
anyway there's a reason that i don't
like to talk about politics because it
just gets me really rowdy it makes
people
just
mad because everybody has their own
opinion and no matter what you tell them
they are correct in their thinking and
there is no swaying it even if they are
not correct let me know what you guys
think of the presidential election
outcome are your friends still being
obnoxious on social networks all right
i'm gonna go make sure you guys
subscribe and uh check out the rest of
my youtube channels i've been trying to
post more on my main channel so check
back here at least monday wednesday
friday those are usually the days that
i'm trying to designate to post even
though today is not a wednesday or a
friday i don't do very well with
schedules
thank you
i'm afraid of you guys